alors bon soir bonjour bon matin la
planète et si tu aimes tu aimes canada
en direct de montréal présentement 11h13
alors de montréal c'est la matinée pour
nous on a deux minutes de retard sont à
travers mais c'est parce qu'il fallait
comme dans un avion qui s'apprête à
prendre son envol vers une destination
vacances il fallait installer les
passagers avec leurs bagages ici un
studio beaucoup de monde bonjour appel
au martinez on va prouver votre micro
dès qu'on va avoir une chance de le
faire si vous êtes là voulez-vous le
crier que vous êtes là merveilleux et
puis chantal alice 7 j'en aime et avec
nous bonjour chantal vous aussi on
ouvrira votre micro dès qu'on va on aura
pris notre envol d'accord
gardez votre ceinture attachée parce que
ça va avoir des turbulences aujourd'hui
marie jobin vous demande à vous aussi de
crier votre présence non gardé ça pour
vous plus fort on vous explique pourquoi
il ya un problème du niveau du son c'est
qu'on essaie de joindre un invité
mystère il restera un mystère pour
encore quelques secondes puisque notre
honte on a toujours un aiguë et oui moi
je sais tout marie je soupçonne qu'elles
incitent quel ancien pas mal écouté on
va aller au vif du sujet pendant qu'on
organise sa conversation que vos micros
ne sont pas bien bien branché à lui mais
c'est ça on al ce qu'on appelle le jeu
de la vidéo en cinq images d'accord et
pendant qu'on va faire jouer cette vidéo
en cinq images
je veux demander maintenant à notre
technicien chef d'allumer les micros on
est prêt pour des collages conditions
c'est officiel saillie launay là
avance yann alors vidéo 5e à chaque
image pour devenir le thème démission
aujourd'hui on part on va vous regarder
les faits ce que vous voyez à l'écran là
ce que tout le monde a apprécié de voir
l'écran et ça prend du temps des fois
décoller une autre affaire mais on est
bien réchauffé malgré tout quant au
canada vous présente l'image du numéro
un thème de la semaine selon vous oui
enfin deux parties une partie de sa wii
effectivement alice beaucoup d'oiseaux
la houlala groïx climatiques sévères ou
s'il est un peu lié à ce thème là oui
effectivement c'est un lien une
influence de luge de la mère aussi ah
oui la mer mais moi ma mère et mon père
ont déjà vu on sent déjà passé proche
avec un bateau de cet endroit numéro 3
est passée rapidement numéro 4 arrive à
l'écran
quel est le thème aujourd'hui l'émission
seles du canada parce que c'est là bas
la gaspésie c'est la gaspésia l'aide
qu'est ce que cela vous le voudrez ça
c'est évident versée oui mon père si
vous avez effectué une percée
non les piercings j'espère en tout cas
si j'avais une cagnotte à gagner vous
auriez percer la cagnotte pour importer
le goal colle aujourd'hui fin on va
parler donc du rocher percé et d'une
percée touristique importante majeur au
rocher percé et de nouveaux équipements
pour accueillir les touristes
et puis c'est un des hauts lieux du
tourisme québécois pas nécessairement
international encore puisque 80 % des
gens qui s'y déplacent sont des
québécois
les autres c'est des canadiens et on
espère peut-être un jour avoir davantage
de touristes qui viennent de rome nous
on va toujours en coton par équipe chez
nous alors écoutez vous connaissez les
missions là le thème de l'émission ça se
déroule en trois ans je le jeu de la
cause bull
j'appelle ça la grosse boule du savoir
la s'élancer
trois questions à l'émission chaque
question vous remportez un certain
nombre de points faut compétitionner
entre vous en général vous êtes tous
gagnants allez les films pour se poser
la question quelle est qu'est-ce qui est
le plus élevé
selon vous on va essayer de mettre les
choses en contexte après tout ce travail
de radio canada international de
personnes mais toujours des choses en
comptait pas parler de la capitale
ottawa ça c'est la capitale n'est ce pas
c'est important alors voici les choses
en contexte concernant le rocher percé
qu'est-ce qui est le plus élevé selon
vous la tour eiffel au lieu du tourisme
mondial ou le rocher percé le haut lieu
du tourisme québécois
moi je dirais la tour eiffel tour eiffel
vous vous tournez la presse
oui les jeux rocher percé rocher percé
tour eiffel a laissé la tour eiffel
c'est la tour eiffel accordez-vous 20
points tous les deux mois elle est
beaucoup plus élevé elle a dit oui
beaucoup plus 324 mètres de hauteur et
puis ça leur fait percer 88 mètres de
haut
par contre si vous pourriez mètres de la
tour eiffel coucher c'est ce que je me
disais le sont la cause parce qu'elle
rachète percée très très massif
alors là là tout rentrerait dans l'ordre
chez par c c'est pas que ça ce qu'on
veut voir si ça marchait pas très bon
c'est un des petits trous du rachis
passe à la caisse
saliou je connais pas les dimensions de
chagrin on va se tourner vers celui qui
a toutes les réponses à toutes ces
questions intelligentes et anodine
oui pourquoi pas d'irriter les jantes
s'agit de rémi plourde
je ne sais pas si nous entend et voit
pas très bien
c'est gagné alors monsieur plourde et le
directeur du parc attendait ce fait
c'est important directeur du parc
national de l'île bonaventure et du
rocher percé mais il ya des gens qui
vous appelle directeur général monsieur
pleure parce que c'est un canon
depuis je vois quelques percées et
nationales de me coiffer tout le moins 2
mondial emblème des poissons facile dans
le monde qui inquiète pendant qu'on se
parle on va tourner des images on va
vous montrer des images notre vidéo ni
aux deux de la semaine où on va faire
une visite aérienne du rocher percé
pendant que vous le décrivez toute la
sphère on va commencer par la question
posée par marie chopin au sujet des
dimensions du trou et ce qui est un gros
tout un petit rond vous savez les 80 71
m donc effectivement la tour eiffel et
20 mètres de diamètre d'envergure ou
l'autre trou
d'ailleurs c'est là la deuxième marche
qui rêvent tous avec le rocher percé
dans son histoire géologique un terme à
34 qu'un quartier passé à percer il y en
avait pas de trouble
non même leur super site est relié avec
le mont joli qu'est un montant qui est
enfin on voit chante les 1 500 victimes
à dans ses voyages avait un coût en face
à 86 les temps dans des meules via réglé
lâche qu'un ampli morutiers les
suppressions de l'implantation de
seigneurie à percer il ya une belle
illustration c'est celle dont on fait
régulièrement 696 on voit pied alors
super sexy du large voix se font
attendre en 1760 avec la conca et
toulouse clermont tient ni straten avec
nick s'appelle robbie cette belle
illustration ou est-ce qu'on voit les
deux belles stars que comparable une à
l'autre et le 7 juin
145 pour la deuxième marche te fondre et
donna en place et lieu à l'obélisque ont
aujourd'hui d'envoyer le le rocher percé
c'est un phénomène géologique dans le
champ ce mode fille
régulièrement d'ailleurs nous on dit
présentement à l'ensemble des clients
tels que les marques chip d'aller
jusqu'à l'os et c'est assez dangereux
savez simple de calcaire s'infiltre
dedans on parle de tout de changement
climatique alors l'autre un fils gel
dégel que debout beaucoup plus d'érosion
que par les années passées donc du
rocher percé pi2 des montagnes sont
autour à chacun de chaque jour fabre est
l'équivalent d'une boîte de camionnettes
pleines de rush tout entière donc je
vous suggère fortement de paille et les
habits mais plutôt de prendre un bateau
une excursion en bateau pour pouvoir
l'observer ces formats plus intéressant
pour moi j'ai vu une image de touristes
qui s'avançait vers le rocher percé ou
lorsqu elle est la mère s'était retirée
c'était la marée basse il marchait vers
le rocher là on les voyait monter sur
les cailloux maintenant comme une plage
vers le rocher est ce que c'est encore
possible de faire ça fait le tombeau
lourds qui leur passent à cet égard nous
on ne concède pas parce que vous savez
pour preuve passer par le cap qu'un nom
ou vous passez par le monde je lis des
montagnes l'euro tant que roche percée
sont soumises à une érosion galopante
ces dernières années des récifs et de
roches
comme je devais une boîte de
camionnettes tonnes de roche à ses skis
temps m'a toujours bien ce secteur
donc pour ça que c'est beaucoup plus
beau si vous montez sur le mongel il
vous avez une vue incroyable sur le
rocher percé si vous allez en excursion
de bateaux lescure ciani pendant toute
la journée font ces excursions l'a
d'ailleurs ils font le tour de relâcher
un bateau pour après aller faire le tour
donc ces excursions l'eau en toute
sécurité vous permet d'avoir une
meilleure vue d'ailleurs savez quand
vous êtes connu sur la paroi de rochers
où vous voyez pas grand-chose phénomène
social qui est cet immense cathédrale de
biak d'autant plus que outre le fait que
c'est une cathédrale de pierre c'est
aussi un tel parc national c'est un
refus dominateur fédéral donc on est on
est en présence d'un des plus gros
afflux ou migrateurs à l'amérique du
nord
on connaît la musique country bassin sur
le baladeur avec ses sens
c'est bien ça mais on va chez percée
c'était tout un coin cd moitry l'actuel
c'est des goélands marengo et la colle
argenté faut être des cormorans dans
toutes ces oiseaux là des niches
écologiques talent proposer différentes
formations géologiques au rocher percé
je me fous de bassan et pourquoi on a
exactement les mêmes conditions que sur
une bande avant sursaut furent la
formation géologique litra de 15,9 pas
de porte une touffe d'agenda les nichées
dans la forêt
comparativement à leur aventure où c'est
du conglomérat
les interviews les grandes tables êtres
sont créés pour s'éduquer rex était
roddick leur permettre 5 rozoy zoo de
berne est d'aller voir s'installer sur
les tablettes de lille comparativement
rocher percé où ils peuvent pas aller
s'installer
voyez il ya vraiment la différence
d'attitude la formation jeu le jeu qui
est à la base je suis plus redevient une
question pour vous à ce rythme-là
d'érosion est ce qu'on risque de voir
vraiment une détérioration as important
du rocher dans les prochains semaines
dans les années à venir
disons 10 années à venir dans les deux
années à venir
je voudrais parler de juste à côté mont
joli où je le vois il y avait il ya
quelques années il y avait l'érosion du
botté est très particulière
alice de côté elle jouera chez père si
vous avez votre la configuration de
vacher est très différente de celle du
côté ouest
donc les éléments sont beaucoup plus
violents les phénomènes d'érosion sont
beaucoup plus qu'à le prendre en compte
est d'ailleurs un immense trou qui est
en train de ski reid premier à la barre
complètement vers le haut alors est-ce
que ça va traverser
est ce que le nouveau trouve a traversé
par en bas j'aurais agi pour faire comme
un oeil aux vaches et où il va monter en
haut donc ça fait les phénomènes
géologiques et tout qui va nous le
démontrer mais choisir comme appiah
quelqu'un dernièrement j'ai dit je veux
montrer les sections père un ouvrier 29
au taux de clôture qui tenait dans telle
approche la clôture qu'il tenait au fait
des vestaires auparavant et ça c'est
tout est rôdé non on le voit prise en
main sur la bordure maritime que les
facteurs d'érosion sont beaucoup plus un
client n'est pas
si vous me demandez l'espérance de vie
de troupe pour quelques la parole à 400
donc on verra
l'espérance de vie des lampes torche y
ont peu à peu près de 15000 à peu près
pour l'ovationner
mais je peux le scénariste match qui
oppose une question les oiseaux il mange
quoi
parce que vous indiquez foot bassin à
l'est pas pour hacher percée mais reste
sur l'île bonaventure
ils se nourrissent de quoi baver le pour
les oiseaux marins
le garde manger des oiseaux c'est tout
le sud du golfe saint laurent les bains
pour particulièrement intéressant ce
niveau là on a fait là on fait toujours
de la chance avec il faut on leur a mis
10 pc maîtrise pour voir ekwalla
tribution toile imaginant ce grand gamin
du football à l'interdît s'intercale
mâles et femelles sont à 30 à 36 heures
environ alors la marque initiation
pertinax ans repêché par de lille bat la
marque sur des singes que dans le fond
d'appels et chaleur longe les cours du
nouveau brunswick seront gelés cours de
nouvelle écosse s'impliquer jusqu'aux et
de la madeleine et revient sur les
ballades calculer la safex à seulement
55 l'allemagne sont à l'intérieur au
petit 30 à 36 heures sur lesquels il
s'intercale basterds je pense je vous
l'avais déjà vu mais quand leurs
techniques de plongée de
l'impressionnant ils sont et permet à
billom des sacs gonflables alors eu long
pour pouvoir plonger profondément
il faut que planches de très haut d'une
trentaine de mètres ils vont avoir une
vision pinacle a comme nous ils vont
faire un book qui a besoin km à la halle
imaginer quelqu'un le capelan serait
imaginé lot 2 3 4 5 6 mélie foot des
cinq tournois avant anciens et bancs de
poissons etc
et là ils vont rentrer d'un couple gay à
12 mètres dos en remontant ils vont
aller chercher le poisson pythie m'en
sortir de l'eau de boisson voit des gens
et travailler
comparativement par exemple une mouette
tridactyle petit en solo pour aller à
céret des poissons et des petits
poissons des petits pingouins qui m'ont
marc med qui vont plonger jusqu'à de 85
à 100 mètres de profondeur pour ali pour
l'action trébuche qui décrochent des
crustacés mollusques paulo d'époisses
envoyés chaque saut à oiseaux à sa
technique de pages chaque oiseau aussi
recèle niches écologiques tout parler
sans doute à la cave et privilégier les
grandes tablettes le foot d'açaï 1.80
miles d'envergure dont il prend de la
place
comparativement des limons marmande et
tout un goy des macareux moine qui vont
s'entasser dans des vins proust et de la
roche et moitry d'accès et qui vont
préférer de pop corn et sont plus agiles
que lego et lynx en un an toutes leurs
prédateurs
donc l'eau s'y niche écologique
technique de page
tous ces éléments ne sont pas un facteur
ici bien plus ça nourrit de ce calcul et
foot dassin ils sont intéressantes le
miel ils vont manger à peu près 50 de
poissons par jour
ils sont ici de la fin mars jusqu'à la
mi octobre
quelques défilés tonnes métriques de
poissons qui s'empêchent dans jaton part
de la richesse du club néerlandais bel
éclat sont fous ces fous bassin a laissé
une dernière question une dernière
question à monsieur cloud dites moi vous
parliez tantôt d'une véritable
cathédrale des pierres nous constatons
d'un autre côté ici que c'est une beauté
dans la nature une beauté en pleine
nature qui doit drainer pas mal de
touristes le long de l'année dites moi
sur le plan touristique malgré l'érosion
fil des ans
c'est quelque chose qui attire pas mal
de gens m'ont beaucoup de des nations
taux refi aimerait avoir comme nous unit
kong ou s'il est impressionnant qu'elle
recherchait donc d'une part c'est une
école d'une part d'un réseau d'eau
migrateurs
c'est un pacte national en plus tu as
l'âge vous disiez que pour la clientèle
québécoise autour de 74 % effectivement
mais juste le fait pour la clientèle
européenne d'avoir des parcs nationaux
dans une région donnée c'est une raison
valable pour des européens par exemple
de déplacer dans la région de l'épire
marqué qu'en gaspésie on est quand même
bien de thé parc national du bic
gaspésie et leur demande sera chez
perdre ses mig oicha en a un à offre de
bi nationaux qui sont toutes
complémentaires qui vous propose tous
une découverte du patrimoine naturel et
culturel que sur quels points d'avancé
percée tout rappelle que dior la
connection le refuge ont mis l'inter
donc la connaît tout à ça et encore la
pluie cesse et mondialement
vous avez les phénomènes géologiques
l'orcher persia 5 pour me changer les
excellentes à percer y en a trois dans
sa synthèse ils se parent club le plus
gros patrimoines bâtis de la femme des
mannequins pâte nationaux du québec
les compagnies josiane les habitants qui
ont vécu sur l'île la salle du
patrimoine a été restauré heavy metal il
fait partie de l'offre touristes et
combien 4 gens qui partent en garde dès
l'été il ya peu près 850 mille personnes
qui parlent sans anesthésie percée est
un point culminant et les coachs d'appel
que ce soit jo pas qu'à percer web
national allemand se rachetait en font
des produits d'après ok ça fait combien
d'années vous répondez aux questions sur
le rocher percé vous êtes la sommité au
québec par rapport à tout ça ça parait
des voix on aime ça toujours un guide
touristique lorsqu'on visite un de ces
endroits là parce qu'on a quand même su
tourner un guitariste passionné par ce
que là ça me donne le goût de partir
voyager avec lui dans le rouge à butry
profiter un ce sont des terrains de jeu
incroyable
il faut il faut ici un plus haut à la
racheter fait un pas vers une île
rechi profiter de votre patrimoine très
bien rémi plourde
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aujourd'hui alors limite
lourde qui est le directeur qui aurait
pu être général du parc n'a pas
seulement écoutés et moi j'aime ça quand
je vais faire du tourisme quand même des
fois de laisser le guide de côté parce
qu'il est bon et de tout risque sont
attroupés autour de lui on part à
l'aventuré mois prend d'une main à
prendre marche est un anglicisme je
pense effectuer une promenade et puis on
va les vidéos numéro trois c'est une
nouveauté c'est depuis juin pas de cette
année mais de 2017
ça fait augmenter le nom de tourisme à
bord j'ai percé c'est une vue aérienne
en fait c'est une vue aérienne sur le
rocher percé grâce à une plateforme
partiquement transparente fait 2-2
méthode oui de vitres tout simplement il
y en a comme ça peu partout dans le
monde mais celle là est vraiment elle
attire le monde et sa fabrication
vous allez voir des images sans vient
d'annoncer des images tournées par des
touristes donc cette année ça va être
suivie d'une vidéo officielle parce
qu'ils sont responsables de cette
construction là qui vont vous montrer
les étapes qui ont mené vers la
construction de cette plateforme qui je
pense est perche à 200 mètres en
altitude
quand même pas tellement élevé le 200 m
mais on indique que c'est plus haut que
le rocher percé impact est une bonne
chose comme ça füle ford
alors on laisse voilà ça s'est vraiment
bien faire regarder voit ses intérêts en
hélicoptère qui vole au dessus de la
plateforme qui elle-même trône au dessus
du rocher pas facile à faire ça a dû
coûter cher et c'est s'est fait parler
le géoparc de percer on va en parler
dans une instance de se jouer au parc
c'est une sorte de musée qui attire
détresse et c'est la nouveauté qui leur
propre ou parce que cela nécessitait
creuset d'un geste précis on n'a pas
seulement jolie dont le nom qui trône
que notre invité devait recevoir dans
son bureau dans kagoshima et douicher
percer un peu plus loin il dans la 20e
mois exactement
merci de nous situer géographiquement me
feras tu sais je suis jamais allé je
suis allé en gaspésie mais pas aux
roches est au projet roche aux fées
c'est demain je vous
je vais aller aller parce que c'est très
beau j'en entends parler de buch tout
[Rires]
cela compte non mais moi je me suis
rendu à gaspésie pas l'habitude sur mer
s'est manqué d'essence
c'est ça ça c est que je voudrais vous
proposer maintenant notre deuxième jeu
oh là là aujourd'hui je vais me
rattraper
vous avez zéro
moi j'aimais aussi alors je de la grosse
boule du savoir deuxième manche
ça vaut pour 30 points d'accord on en a
parlé avec notre invité
alors j'espère un peu de mémoire ce
n'est pas de connaissances pour moi vous
aurez de la mémoire au début du 16e
siècle explorateur français jacques
cartier pouvait voir combien d'argent
rocheuse dans leur fameux rocher percé
0,1 2,3 ou aucune de ces réponses
j à 10,0 je pense qu'en pensez vous
[Musique]
maryse oui moi je tairai 2-2 d'accord
j'ai zéro g 2 est ce que vous les épaves
between je dirais 1 1
pierre nos techniciens et vous dit
combien 0 vous aussi oui c'est ça qui
l'a dit à l'écouté vous avez dit 0 c
zéro il a dit qu'au début c'était 0 puis
qu'il avait eu de rappeler je ne dépasse
pas subitement non j'ai serré mais quand
l'explorateur français jacques cartier
est arrivé il y avait trois arches dans
la formation rocheuse sexy et non les
supplie de la plaque
ce n'est pas un problème on a le on a
luxe et de pouvoir les emmener
après l'émission danger soit 0 soit
rambo c'était 3 ha bon 3 selon les
informations écrites alors vous avez
tous est donc là
j'adore ces jeux parce que on va parler
du géoparc wima géoparc de percer donc
c'est allez voir c'est le musée vous
allez sur le quai voir prendre le bateau
gong si vous allez dans un bateau où
vous allez monter vers le musée pour
avoir des explications plus géologique
lucien s'est fait que par rapport à ça
je suis prêt pour le troisième jeu ça va
tellement je veux qu'on détermine un
gagnant coup de coude d'accord je sens
que ça presse parce qu'on à 0 20 30 hier
et moi peut-être que la prochaine
question va clore le débat
d'accord c'est bon pour 50 points le
rocher de gilbratar j'ai parlé de la
mise en contexte à ercis qui est
important oui d'accord le rocher de
gibraltar gibraltar
c'est jim holt même la plus belle
impression de parler comme le capitanat
dans le rocher de gibraltar est un
monolithe calcaire c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est wikipédia qui est située à
gibraltar
oui d'accord sur la côte méridionale de
la péninsule ibérique railway soyons
précis
voilà alors on à la péninsule
gaspésienne l'autre côté on a la
péninsule ibérique
enfin non
[Rires]
voici la question en hauteur il faudrait
empilés combien de rocher percé place
est donc un ou deux sus de l'autre pour
atteindre le sommet du rocher de
gibraltar
vous avez un choix de réponse 3 x ray
donnez moi j'allais voir les premiers
contre le premier parti de votre cost et
la 1er partie de votre contexte nos
enjeux de gibraltar et céda première
partie chiffres là non auteur il
faudrait rappeler combien de rocher
percé placer un ou deux sus de l'autre
atteint 2 sommet du rocher de gibraltar
3 x 5 x ou dix fois trois fois
djibo 5 x 5 x moi aussi j'irai avec 5 5
x 5 x pour emporter le jeu c'est toi 50
points comme ça
oui il faut dire la vérité c'était au ps
avait 50 points à 81 points c'est gagné
fantastique sinon d'enfants le sommet de
gilbratar sait combien de mètres le
sommet de judée voltaire non trois fois
je pensais qu'à parler d'un sommet
économique de parce que s'ils auraient
percé 88
il suit à trois ça fait combien autour
de 215 quelques galets la bonne la mort
est bon c'est ça ces cinq gagnants cette
fac parce que le sommeil le sommeil
madame est d'être quelqu'un vient
cruellement de temps calme et là
quelques jours sur le sommet
mais ouais c'est 426 mètres de cela la
bramer français nous 170 élèves c'est ma
formation 70 points tous les deux
alors oui alors c'est c'est même avec
vous le 58 88 mais qui perd 5 même avec
le 50.9 gagnant 3 gagne notre on a eu
beaucoup de plaisirs simples sont
mentionnés c'est que sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine on le fait
à chaque semaine soit on n'a pas le
temps d'en parler aujourd'hui non plus
n'aura pas le temps sérieusement on a ce
qu'on appelle nos meilleurs coups de la
semaine vous avez pas travailler avec
nous non cette semaine
paloma elle nous a fait un plaisir
extraordinaire dans je sais je travaille
cette semaine la section espagnole
j'ai plein de choses à faire mais je
veux revenir faire un tour cette semaine
avec toi c'est gentil merci très
appréciée genre très agréable toujours
sait tous qu'une collègue 1 sera
quelqu'un de bien elle allie très
contagieuse alors dans les meilleurs
coups cette semaine on parle de paul
gérin lajoie tout à fait qui est décédé
quand même il ya plusieurs semaines mais
là cette semaine y avait quelque chose
de spécial au québec
oui funérailles nationales pour paul
gérin lajoie il est connu pour sous le
nom de p g l pourquoi caudines dicter à
cause d'une fondation à cause du fait
qu'il a été un des pères de la
révolution tranquille mais aussi de
l'accès gratuit à l'éducation au québec
et dans les années 70 rideau de fils de
justin qui émettent un premier ministre
qui l'avait nommé à la tête de l'acdi
quelle agence canadienne de
développement international et lui avait
dit vas-y ouvre des portes et c'est ce
qu'il a fait je vais vous demander
question pour les nuls chez moi ça
existe encore la xxiiie tout à fait mans
intéressant que vous posez cette
question là parce que moi cette semaine
je fais une entrevue avec mario renoux
il est cofondateur du groupe de
réflexion sur le développement
international et la coopération
il a connu monsieur monsieur lajoie et
il avait ceci à dire à propos de
monsieur lajoie et 10 en mission les
gens le receveur le nommant monsieur le
président il allait en afrique mais ont
très connu il était toujours très à
l'écouté très sensible dans ses
approches à ces approches
il a pu développer une collaboration
germain une amitié avec les dirigeants
des pays qu'ils visitent et il dit que
ça c'était la marque de commerce de
l'acdic à cette époque là alors à
écouter sur notre site internet au monde
présentement les images il ya aussi un
sujet que vous avez préparé sur le râle
à verdun avant donc c'est quelque chose
de très très attrayant sur deux ans en
france mont verdun une banlieue de
montréal l'écouté on est chez nous on
n'est pas en france j'espère tellement
de jfl tentons mais nous restons au
canada avec près de montréal dans la
grande agglomération de montréal si vous
voulez à verdun donc j'ai parlé de l'art
mural avec madame elisabeth d'or c'est
la directrice générale d'un organisme
qui s'appelle mur et qui oeuvrent dans
cet art là depuis une douzaine d'années
et donc ils ont décidé de revitaliser
tout un quartier industriel à verdun et
puis franchement le résultat est superbe
donc on a je sais pas si on a l'image du
tableau donc
je vais vous décrire un peu ce que c'est
c'est un tableau qui ressemble à de la
bande dessinée où on a toutes sortes de
personnages qui attirent des enfants des
curieux et même des adultes chacun veut
bâtir une histoire autour de cet art
mural et puis ça crée une espèce
d'émulation dans le quartier imaginé un
quartier tristounet un parc industriel
perdu qui retrouve une espèce de vie
avec ce tableau de l'artiste
astro ses années de gloire de la
muraille valeur à l'intitulé pts en
entrevue
finalement on a donc cette image là
voyez vous on a le maire jean françois
parenteau on a des habitants du quartier
qui sont là donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très très beaux de très très
coloriste vous voulez donc on a des
images comme ça des personnages tant qu
on se croirait dans un dessin animé
tantôt ça ressemble plutôt à une bande
dessinée
et puis un garagiste du coin qui s'est
dit mais je trouve ça très beau je crois
que je vais m'inspirer de cet art là
pour repeindre un peu mon garage qui est
tous vieux tous tristes et finalement
c'est un quartier qui retrouve une
espèce de vie et les gens sont contents
les passants aussi qu'il regarde tout le
ps c'est quelque chose qui crée de
l'attrait donc moi ça ça m'a fasciné
moi je pense qu'on aurait dû s'inspirer
de ça pour mur de berlin il a aussi fait
quelque chose sur le chanvre est la
boisson
on a montré les images et quelques
instants oui j'ai un petit sujet que
j'ai fait hier sur le chanvre dont il ya
des jeunes qui ont l'intention de mettre
en place une espèce de boissons à base
de chanvre à base de dérivés du chanvre
et c'est un produit qui est en ce moment
interdite au canada je sais pas il
appelait ça le kanak cannabinoïdes
quelque chose comme ça et donc c'est un
produit qui est interdit pour le moment
au canada et qui va être commercialisé
aux états unis où les gens connaissent
davantage le produit pour ses vertus
thérapeutiques
donc c'est un produit qui peut
s'appliquer aussi comme une huile
c'est bon pour toute la famille non non
non non non pas pour les enfants
forcément il vous voyez vous c'est un
produit qui n'est pas autorisé au pays
mais qui est quand même utiliser admis
aux états unis donc pour le moment ils
sont en train de mettre en place leur
marque et c'est une marque qui va aller
à la conquête du marché international
dont on est alors on leur souhaite
beaucoup de chance beaucoup de courage
dans leurs initiatives ou de chambre oui
beaucoup de chance j'ai dit 'je donc
voilà c'est des jeunes très très
dynamique très motivés et qu'ils sont
soutenus par l'organisme lg2 dont ils
ont formé un partenariat pour pouvoir
mettre en place ce produit là et
franchement c'est un produit qui
s'annonce vraiment prometteur sur le
marché belge et deux non d'une centrale
et non c'est pas une centrale est rentré
que c'est un organisme qui fait dans la
promotion de l'innovation qui qui
oeuvrent auprès des jeunes qui ont des
idées novatrices et qui veulent aller à
l'angop à la conquête du marché mondial
alger donc la compagnie qui fabrique
l'électronique comprends tous ces deux
images ces deux noms qui se ressemblent
mais qui sont engagés dans du domaine je
fais totalement différents titres a dit
heureusement on a le site internet pour
connaître les détails et le fin fond de
cette histoire
merci beaucoup je me présentais mon cas
j'étais sur le bateau pendant trois
heures le soleil la plongée pas loin du
rocher percé fait j'ai commencé un pl
était magnifique et et on nous promet qu
être quelques jours de beau temps enfin
après une semaine un peu mouvementée
côté température côté attend oui c'est
plus frais maintenant la semaine
prochaine tout va bien avec hertz chaîne
de la section chinoise de la vie canada
international merci à vous merci
beaucoup de nous avoir seconde est
aujourd'hui appuyée techniquement les
absences de léo puis aussi de notre
webmestre du côté français dont j'ignore
même trou de mémoire en corner
marie claude
pendant très longtemps oui à tout ce
beau monde à 15 je pense profitez-en
on retrouve la came ont dit au revoir à
quelques caméras aujourd'hui on va le
numéro 36 mais en 38 numéro de train ne
score pas c'est plutôt derrière ou non -
avants numéro 62 à la semaine prochaine
à bail la planète était magnifique et et
on nous promet quelques jours de beau
temps bien de la section merci à vous
merci beaucoup de nous avons seconde est
aujourd'hui appuyé de notre ingénieur
mémoire trouve la caméra on dire voir à
quelle caméra aujourd'hui on va le
numéro 36 mais en 38 numéro 62